this just happened breaking news uh the
U.S just launched an ICBM into the
Pacific Ocean
so sick it's unarmed don't worry U.S
launches unarmed ICBM into Pacific Ocean
and amid China North Korea tensions for
those aren't familiar it means
intercontinental ballistic missile
typically what we use to put uh to to
transport nuclear warheads to place them
very quickly onto a city in order to
make that City not a city anymore
so we were just talking the other day
about the Doomsday Clock
and we were
meaning on it I think
I think that was it kind of second to
midnight but now you know we're we're
launching icbms as a show of force
because that's clearly what it was so
this was I guess yesterday yesterday
night in the so it's like 11 p.m Pacific
time
sorry keep going no well I I apparently
it's not today but even still it's it's
still saber rattling and you've got you
know the U.S sending military aid and
stuff to Russia and we've got this this
at least escalation of tensions with
China even if it's just marginally you
can't get super nervous when North Korea
launches missile I don't blame them you
know what I mean I mean there's a reason
people do these things it's not just
coincidental the North Koreans do not
like the Japanese you know
um so I don't blame them you know and
and I don't I don't understand why
people are so
Cavalier about
the behavior of the administration it
seems clear to me that we should be
trying to de-escalate and yet the
current Administration is is completely
comfortable doing everything it can go
ahead John Ball let me ask you what I
was gonna say what is John Fulton
representative let's be specific what
does de-escalation actually look like
doing what the United States should not
be giving uh money or uh Aid to Ukraine
in my opinion
um let's focus on Taiwan because this is
um a little bit china-centric here okay
do you think
um arming China arming Taiwan with more
arms makes it more or less likely that
China will invade Taiwan or attempt an
invasion of Taiwan I think that there is
going to be an invasion of Taiwan
regardless of what happens and I think
the United States is not in a position
to defend Taiwan because of the nuclear
missiles that China has and proximity
the Strait of Taiwan means that if China
lands in Taiwan they can supply the
occupying Army by FL by just owning the
street your answer was either way though
the what would make it such that China
is more or less likely to invade if
Taiwan is more or less I think I don't I
don't know that there is one that will
make it more or less I don't know that I
have an opinion that there is going to
be an invasion eventually I think Xi
Jinping made a calculation I think Mao
Zedong has said this in the past too
they will invade Taiwan when they think
they will be able to successfully invade
and incorporate Taiwan so as long as
Taiwan is strong enough to um repel that
Invasion China will not invade I think
so that's why us arming Taiwan and
making alliances with South Korea with
India with Australia with Japan with the
Philippines
um with Vietnam even is what's helping
um deter China from anything I agree but
I also think that China
uh is is too massive and it's too many
resources that it can centralize just
outside of Taiwan that no Taiwan can
only have so much military power China
can amass substantially more and then
eventually there's nothing we can do to
stop them I mean that that's what it
comes to it's the timing of when China
thinks they could successfully invade I
don't think they think they could
successfully now I don't think that
China and when they did think so is when
they would invade which is why we could
never allow them to get to that point I
don't think that that China is going to
be in a general I don't think that China
is
is waiting on a po a a military
situation in Taiwan that is beneficial
to them I think that they are more
waiting on a situation at home here in
the U.S where the U.S is not in a
position to defend Taiwan well these
things over the lap though but what
would that be what would that be what
position would we be in the U.S well if
we if we get into any kind of Act of
conflict with Russia we're not going to
be able to deal with it but if our
citizens don't trust our government but
China's backstopping Russia at this
point too so world war three all right
well I mean I mean also like Iran we're
having our Ally Israel bomb different
drone facilities in Iran which is
supplying supplying drones to
um Ukraine Russia to attack Ukraine so
we are getting in this tense Powder Keg
the Allies clearly are lined up but
again you know the threshold for what
would allow these conflicts to happen is
whether or not our allies are strong
enough to repel these attacks and our
our enemies know this so if Ukraine was
strong enough if Russia thought that
would be strong enough to repel them
back then they wouldn't have invaded to
begin with
Putin's part Ukraine is not our Ally we
are not in we're not in any kind of in
uh uh any kind of uh treaty with them
yes we are though have I think it's the
Budapest memorandum when we made them
agreed to relinquish their nukes and we
said they would we would protect them
from Invasion we walked away from that
with Crimea
um I mean is we should have doubled down
when uh Russia initially tried to take
Crimea but again that's was filled with
like obscurities about how it was Little
Green Men and it wasn't actually
supposed to be Russia but I agree with
you we should have done something when
is crime yeah and now when they did an
actual Invasion where it's not Little
Green Men where it's actually Russia you
know I'm glad that we're letting Ukraine
defend itself and I'll let you know
something if Russia didn't think they'd
be able to successfully invade Ukraine
they they wouldn't and part of uh we
could help contribute to that factor so
that's why when Trump was President
Putin did not try
doubling down on our allies in the
Pacific he got um Japan to like I forgot
what the exact percent was but highly
increased the amount that they're
contributing to our American bases we're
doubling down we have a bunch of
Partnerships I don't know the acronyms
both Australia India South Korea the
Philippines all the homies in the
Pacific we will not back down to the
Communists in China and um Trump was
great foreign policy there were there
were issues with it of course we can
criticize everybody if we if we want to
find reasons criticize and there are
things I think we can but come on man
not only that you're right but he was
talking with North Korea and I want to
make sure everybody hears this I've said
it 50 billion times
when Trump crossed into North Korea from
the DMZ he had no security yeah he
walked into what is ostensibly enemy
territory in a show of trust and good
faith to bring peace
they walked up smiled and shook hands
and walked back Trump was alone with
enemy troops around him he put his life
on the line but he was smart he knew
they're not going to do anything it's
like you want the U.S to come and wipe
you off the start of war so he knew he
could make this effort but I I have
tremendous respect for that that was a
powerful moment and it's crazy to me
that
this is what scares me about the future
the people who are willing to vote for
Joe Biden without knowing anything about
what's going on and then immediately
what happens Russia starts amassing
troops on the border we get War
and I and and and he's just dumping
money into dumping the money to it look
before he was before Trump got elected
you had escalating conflict with Ukraine
and Russia particularly because of U.S
Western involvement in Ukraine and
Russia and the tensions and there was
conflict emerging and then Trump gets
elected and it kind of stops and then
biting itself back there we go again and
some people have said on the left
liberals well it's because Trump was
doing Putin's bidding and it's like oh
yes he was he was de-escalating U.S
influence operations in this territory
resulting in a de-escalation of war and
conflict and kind of stabilizing things
he was wiping out Isis and kind of
stabilizing areas in the Middle East he
was bringing about the Abraham Accords
what is wrong with people like they're
just so tribal that they would vote for
someone like Joe Biden whose records
been been apocalyptic going back to his
Obama years which is completely orange
man bad they're just totally ignorant
though Trump had an amazing foreign
policy in part two is I think it was a
national security advisor a policy
advisor it's John Bolton John Bolton's
who I'm talking about I'm just teasing I
will I will say Trump made a really good
point he said uh someone told me I don't
know if he said this but someone said
Trump said it so correctly if I'm wrong
but when he would go to negotiate and
then this these people would walk in and
Shake Trump's hand and then Bolton would
pop up behind him they'd go huh like all
of a sudden you know Trump's like I want
you to meet my friend the guy who's just
begging me to blow up your country it's
like what do you want whatever you need
like they know he's he's serious so the
mustache is very intimidating guys I
mean I can I can I can say there's a net
positive to to to Bolton's personality
when he said this time next year we'll
be celebrating in Tehran I was like
that's that's insane that's crazy but
maybe talking crazy freaks people out
and makes people back off I you know I
don't like the guys I actually believe
legitimately he would bring us to that
war so I'm not interested but I can at
least say the rhetoric does have the
purpose of not having the war happen and
making people back off John Bolton has
never seen a bomb that he does not want
to drop on someone hasn't seen a
terrorist he hasn't wanted blown up uh
shout out to kasim suleimani in pieces
when do you expect uh hashtag uh Bolton
Bros trend on Twitter it would only it
would only be because of this mustache
on this show so if not right now
probably never I think he has a failing
um surge might have inspired me
originally I think he came out so we'll
see where John Bolton goes this is
partly tongue-in-cheek I've just been
rocking every every man here has a
hold on like you've shaved have a
mustache Serge I think you've also
selectively shaven your face I can only
grow a mustache let's be real I just
don't do anything I just ignore it until
it gets uncamped and then I trim it down
with buzzers I shave my neck I mean I
can't grow a beard for real people have
a weird Korean thing to shave my beard a
lot every day it grows in real thick
it's really sad don't tell them the
secrets feminists would say it's
empowering they have a beard I think
they call them they would lie to you too
it doesn't matter the female mustache is
the lip as I understand that's what they
call it is the lip no like when they say
shave my lip they're talking about their
mustache so women can you folks and Bros
too you are so fabulous I identify as a
Bolton bro you guys would grow nice
Alton bro stashes oh I know that's an
insult
I know
really you know people want to shave
they gotta shave you gotta keep your
beards you got to grow your beards yeah
it must be weird I remember when I was
little uh my mom told me that uh
guys don't like beards like they they
like beards look good or whatever but
shaving sucks like that's what guys tend
to say and I'm like man I can't imagine
what it'll be like to not have a beard
like I don't have like a crazy beard but
facial hair never really shaver I've
only like started rocking the full beard
in the past like six months I think I
last night like November is when I like
stopped shaving and No Shave November
yeah like and so now it's like and the
reason I never had a mustache is I
always thought it came in like spotty
and crappy and then apparently it's just
like Phil we'll welcome you to the
bulletin bro Squad I mean don't worry
whatever mustache you could achieve it's
a legitimate mustache
but the beard is there obscuring your
fandom for John Bolton I I have no
fandom for John Bolton easy sure those
kind of you do have a mustache easy easy
with that thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time